bonsoir nous sommes le 30 octobre
renouvelle édition du Journal de la
rédaction et dans l'actualité locale
aujourd'hui le verdict pour un ancien
policier soupçonné de viol sur une femme
d'une et quarantaine d'années au sein du
commissariat de Mantes-la-Jolie la cour
d'assise de Versailles la condamné à 10
ans de prison pierre riveuse tuquille
nommé président d'Yvelines informations
jeunesse la structure qui craignait
encore pour son avenir voici quelques
mois repart sur de nouvelles bases avec
le soutien du Conseil Général qui arrive
tu qui invitée de cette édition un
puzzle de 200000 pièces un passionnés
d'aviation en pleine reconstitution d'un
avion de chasse à Ellis des années 40
rencontre tout à l'heure avec cette
Yvelines wa installé à Saint-Cyr-l'École
qui nous présentera sa réplique d'un
Mustang la CGT dans la tourmente après
les révélations du Canard enchaîné sur
le logement de son président Thierry
lepont le syndicat aurait financé 130
000 euros de travaux de rénovation à
fond perdu puisqu'elle n'est pas
propriétaire de l'appartement situé dans
le bois de Vincennes dans une note
interne destinée aux organisations en
région et aux militants la direction
évoque une offensive médiatique souvent
à détourner l'attention des prochaines
mobilisations du syndicat prévu elle est
quatre et 11 novembre dans les
transports et dans la fonction publique
nous sommes en ligne avec
Eric Prevost bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le responsable
départemental de la CGT dans les
Yvelines comment vous réagissez à ces
révélations qui n'ont pour l'instant pas
été démenti par la CGT
alors où on se parle je n'ai pas
d'autres informations que ce que j'ai lu
dans la presse ou le communiqué
confédéral que vous venez d'évoquer
000 euros ait été utilisés pour rénover
ce logement
de fonction à un dirigeant de province
c'est une question normale pour qu'il
puisse mener son activité et puis
d'autre part avoir une vie personnelle
et se reposer autant que de besoin quoi
voilà donc nous avons une réunion
nationale mardi et mercredi qui était
programmé sur sur la situation sociale
du pays
qui me préoccupe moi en tant que
dirigeant c'est l'avenir industriel du
département les conditions de travail
des salariés etc etc voilà plutôt ces
questions là est-ce qu'il est normal
pour vous que cet argent servent à ça
justement à rénover le logement qu'il
est un logement j'imagine que c'est
entendu pour pour tout le monde même
pour les militants mais que les
militants après par voie de presse que
130 000 euros ce sont des cotisations
notamment qui sont utilisées pour faire
des travaux de ce montant là de cette
ampleur l'interrogation elle est ce que
vous venez de dire c'est qu'il y a une
révélation dans un journal
le journaux publient la même chose
repris télévision et je trouve plutôt
surprenant c'est cette attention
exceptionnelle pour pour la CGT quoi
voilà donc il y a pas eu démenti jusqu'à
présent il aurait peut-être fallu qu'il
y ait des éclaircissements pour pour
éviter peut-être l'emballement est-ce
que les militants en tout cas vous ont
contacté consultés comment est
réagissent justement comment vous
réagissez dans la section locale des
Yvelines d'abord j'ai pas j'ai pas eu de
coup de fil
j'en ai rencontré hier parce
qu'aujourd'hui je suis en congé donc
j'en ai pas rencontré aujourd'hui bon
bah voilà on est on est dans l'attente
de d'informations précises bon peut-être
s'il y a pas de démenti peut-être que
c'est vrai moi 130 000 € vous savez pour
rénover un logement aujourd'hui
est-ce que ça peut en tout cas une
dernière question tâcher l'image de la
CGT est-ce que ça peut pénaliser aussi
vos mobilisations comme c'est dit dans
ce communiqué qui a été diffusé
notamment auprès de vous auprès des
différentes instances régionales est-ce
que ça va bloquer un petit peu la suite
des mobilisations
non je pense je pense qu'on va continuer
à travailler moi pour ce qui me concerne
dans le département
je suis concentré sur la préparation
d'une conférence sur l'industrie c'est
quelque chose qui est sur lequel on
travaille en permanence donc voilà on
continue à travailler
et à faire des choses pour pour
l'intérêt des salariés quoi voilà merci
avec prévu d'avoir été en ligne avec
nous ce soir pour réagir donc assez
révélations jusqu'à présent du Canard
enchaîné sur le logement du président de
la CGT au niveau national Thierry le
pont est justement nous sommes allés
aussi vous demander dans les rues de 50
ans en Yvelines comment vous réagissiez
assez révélations vos réponses bah c'est
pratique connu en France plus on est au
placés puis on s'en met plein les poches
c'est la continuité de toute façon tout
ce qui est politique et magouille alors
on découvre des des affaires
dangereux des fraudes et tout c'est tous
les jours de toute façon
c'est vraiment des parades de se dire
que on peut refaire son appartement de
fonction avec l'argent public c'est tout
je suis pas très étonné
qu'on puisse avoir des comportements de
ce type même venant d'un responsable
syndical justice le verdict est donc
tombé dans la soirée pour le policier
soupçonné de viol 10 ans de réclusion un
veridict conforme réquisition de
l'avocat général écouter
le brigadier avait plaidé le malentendu
sexuel mais les jurés de la cour
d'assises de Versailles en ont jugé
autrement ils ont suivi les réquisitions
de l'avocat général et ont condamné
l'ancien policier de Mantes-la-Jolie à
10 ans de prison pour le viol le 6 mai
2012 d'une femme dans l'enceinte du
commissariat ce jour-là cette femme de
44 ans alcoolisée est emmenée par les
policiers pour être placés en cellule de
dégrisement elle aura une relation
sexuelle avec le brigadier en charge de
la Garde de Nuit ce dernier a assuré
qu'elle était consentante la victime
elle a parlé de cauchemars les jurés ont
donc tranché en estimant qu'il
s'agissait bien d'un viol commis par
personne abusant de l'autorité que lui
confère ses fonctions la peine prononcée
est une peine de 10 ans d'emprisonnement
et des dommages et intérêts ont été
alloués à ma cliente ainsi qu'à son mari
très soulagé que la culpabilité était
retenue
elle n'a pas fait de commentaires
particuliers sur la durée de la peine
d'emprisonnement c'est une peine qui est
importante évidemment ça reste un homme
qui n'a pas de casier judiciaire qui a
des enfants qui a un avenir donc c'est
une peine relativement lourde mais il
encourait quand même 20 ans
d'emprisonnement au départ on a un
dysfonctionnement au sein d'une
institution pour que finalement des
institutions interviennent comme elles
le devait l'avocat du policier n'était
pas joignable ce jeudi le policier
pourrait faire appel du jugement il a
jusqu'à mardi pour donner sa décision
35 voitures endommagées à coups de
bâtons et de baseball avec Guyancourt
dans le quartier des garennes la nuit a
été pour le moins agité des abributs
sont aussi été détruits par une
vingtaine de casseurs et les auteurs des
faits n'ont pas encore été retrouvés par
la police l'enquête pour dégradation
volontaire en réunion CE poursuit
politique avec l'entrée en vigueur de la
loi à mon le premier novembre le député
socialiste des Yvelines à beau avoir
quitté le gouvernement à la fin de l'été
il agace encore le patronat en effet les
employeurs vont maintenant être obligés
d'informer leurs salariés de moi avant
s'ils souhaitent vendre leur entreprise
les organisations patronales parle à
d'un des créatures de je vous rappelle
que Benoît Hamon était cette semaine
l'invité du 7 8 politique l'émission est
à revoir sur Internet grâce au Replay et
puis on reste dans la politique avec ses
propos à présent de Robert à Cadalbert
ce sera à découvrir dans quelques jours
sur cette antenne dans PAF l'émission de
débat proposé par Patrice kermos
l'ancien président de l'agglomération de
50 ans en Yvelines est invité à revenir
sur les conditions de son départ de la
vie politique locale avant les élections
de mars il évoquait souvenez-vous un
choix mûrement réfléchi il concède
aujourd'hui qu'il a été invité à ne pas
se représenter écouter
certaines personnes me disent oui bon
effectivement c'était pas mon choix le
choix que j'avais fait c'était de dire
bon je me redonne encore trois ans je
vais jusqu'à la rider Cup et je passerai
la main voilà les maires de gauche n'ont
pas décidé comme ça ils ont décidé non
non l'élection municipale c'est d'abord
municipal c'est pas à l'intercommunalité
donc l'interprété on ne veut pas dans la
dans la discussion de de cette campagne
je pense que je regarde d'autant plus
que vu les résultats on peut penser que
si on avait fait une campagne
intercommunale sur les résultats de
l'agglomération qui sont indéniables
peut-être que le résultat a répété tout
à fait la même mais c'est l'histoire
maintenant et ben allons de l'avant
peuvent présenter donc par Patrice
karmouz émission complète à suivre ce
week-end sur l'antenne de TVfil on passe
à l'invité de cette édition du 30
octobre Pierrick bonjour et bienvenue
vous êtes le nouveau président à divine
Information Jeunesse Yvelines
informations jeunesse yij centre
d'information sur le logement le travail
les études font des en 1974 et financé
par le Conseil général basé à Versailles
il y a aussi des déclinaisons à travers
le département avant l'été cette
structure elle est mal les salariés
étaient inquiets il n'y avait plus de
président en place pas de financement
aujourd'hui tout va mieux lui tout va
mieux aujourd'hui grâce en particulier
mon prédécesseur immédiat la joie en
maire de Versailles François-Xavier
Bellamy qui a accepté de faire une
mission d'intérim il avait vraiment
qualifié comme ça pour apaiser la
structure et le fait je le remercie pour
le travail qu'il a fait avec les cinq
salariés de la structure qui aujourd'hui
j'arrive sur une situation qui est quand
même beaucoup plus saine et qui nous
permet maintenant d'envisager de
consolider de redévelopper la structure
on va parler du développement envisagé
mais comment comment expliquer ces
difficultés pour cette transition le
l'absence d'un président la transition
ensuite qui a été assurée vous l'avez
dit elle ces inquiétudes sur le
financement les inquiétudes sur le
financement et s'inscrit dans un
contexte qui est difficile puisque on
est financé vous l'avez dit par le
conseil général mais aussi par la
Direction Départementale de la Cohésion
sociale on connaît un peu les
difficultés aujourd'hui de toutes les
structures publiques et les
collectivités et puis c'est peut-être
aussi une structure qui est animée
pendant très longtemps par une équipe
qui était là quasiment depuis l'origine
et je pense qu'on est arrivé à la fin
d'un cycle et que voilà maintenant il y
a une nouvelle équipe qui arrive avec
des un bureau qui est sérieusement
rajeuni avec un financement assuré
est-ce que votre arrivée coïncide avec
l'arrivée de moyens aussi alors le
financement ça reste toujours un sujet
on sait bien que l'État se désengage est
réduit ses dotations ça se traduit aussi
pour les collectivités donc aujourd'hui
on roule pas sur l'or loin sans faux
donc on va continuer à se battre pour
l'assurer mais voilà on a de quoi
continuer notre activité vous avez été
responsable du Point Information
Jeunesse sur Fontenay-le-Fleury là vous
prenez la tête d'Yvelines informations
genèse de manière durable on n'est pas
dans la transition
bien et avant de en débutant cet
entretien sur la question financière se
pose des questions sur la question
peut-être aussi de la réussite de cette
structure est-ce qu'aujourd'hui une
information jeunesse répond
véritablement à une attente parce que
j'imagine que si les deux mondes étaient
importantes la question du financement
de poserait même pas et bien les
demandes sont importantes voilà on
accueille
enfin le nombre de visites et d'accueils
qui sont réalisés en ligne ou
physiquement ces deux ordres de 260 000
chaque année donc ce qui est très
important c'est de plus en plus en ligne
d'ailleurs c'est jusqu'à 25000 personnes
qui sont accueillies soit dans les
locaux donc il y a vraiment du monde qui
vient et on voit bien les thématiques
qui correspondent vraiment à des besoins
sur tout ce qui touche à l'insertion et
à l'insertion professionnelle en
particulier et aussi au logement qui est
vraiment un sujet important vous dites
ça évoluer la façon aussi de chercher
l'information Internet et qui est
forcément beaucoup plus présent dans le
quotidien des plus jeunes il fait une
information jeunesse doit faire une
mutation doit revoir complètement son
positionnement sa façon de revoir
complètement mais en tout cas le
repenser en intégrant beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus en profondeur
ce qu'on peut faire en ligne
l'articulation entre le service en ligne
on a aujourd'hui 120 000 visites chaque
année sur notre site ce qui est
important donc finalement le premier
point d'information c'est aujourd'hui
clairement Internet et donc ça il faut
l'articuler et voir du coup quelle est
la valeur ajoutée du service qu'on peut
rendre lorsqu'on accueille physiquement
quelqu'un et aussi un des points qui est
important pour moi c'est l'articulation
avec les autres structures on va pas
répondre tout seul à tout on n'a pas
compétence sur tous les domaines et je
souhaite qu'on développe davantage
encore les liens avec les missions
locales avec les Pôle emploi avec les
autres structures qui relèvent de
l'orientation pour les remplacer faut
travailler réussissiez à travailler
ensemble vous parliez des locaux ça veut
dire que la situation en géographique
acquise à Versailles pour être mise en
cause pour y partir ça pourrait arriver
voilà j'espère qu'on pourra rester
encore mais effectivement tout peut être
amené à très interroger s'il le faut
voilà en tout cas si on bouge il faut
qu'on reste dans un endroit très
accessible pour tout le département
parce que on accueille évidemment
beaucoup de versaillers parce que c'est
une grande ville et qu'on est à
Versailles mais on accueille vraiment
des jeunes qui viennent de tout le
département donc ils viennent
d'information jeunesse ne pourrait ne
plus être qu'un seul point de
rendez-vous virtuel sur Internet
vous vous écartez pas l'idée de rester
il faut vraiment qu'on maintienne
l'accueil on le souhaite la direction
départementale de la cohésion sociale il
tient aussi donc voilà il y a ce double
rôle qu'il faut garder en permanence à
la fois d'animer le réseau des de la
quarantaine de points et de Bureau
information jeunesse mais aussi d'être
un lieu d'accueil physique pour tous les
jeunes qui le souhaitent peut-être
préciser vos missions vous disiez il
faut renforcer l'aide au logement l'aide
à l'insertion professionnelle la
principale demande aujourd'hui des
jeunes c'est quoi on vient vous voir
pourquoi et quelle réponse vous apportez
est-ce que tout finit finalement par
sourire à ces jeunes qui viennent vous
voir tout fonctionne vous avez la
recette miracle si on avait une recette
miracle on la vendrait très cher non par
contre et de très loin la première
demande touche à l'emploi mais l'emploi
sur toutes ses facettes depuis l'aide à
bâtir un programme de formation quelles
sont les bonnes quelles sont les métiers
très souvent les métiers sont pas connus
beaucoup de jeunes pensent à un secteur
d'activité donc il faut les aider à
découvrir ce que c'est qu'un métier il
faut les aider parfois aussi à faire les
démarches faire un CV faire une lettre
de motivation donc on a régulièrement
des ateliers là dessus on a une activité
qui marche bien d'offres de Job parce
qu'on a après 5000 le job référencé sur
le site John au stock donc c'est de très
loin la première demande et la deuxième
après c'est tout ce qui touche au
logement on a un service d'aide de
logement avec un peu moins de 200 offres
de logements qui sont référencés chaque
année donc pour la deuxième demande et
puis après il y a une activité de BAFA
on organise plusieurs sessions de BAFA
chaque année avec 80 jeunes qui en ont
profité l'an dernier également une
activité de vente de voyage tous les ans
on peut faire voyage linguistique au
voyage tout simplement touristique donc
il y a aussi cette activité d'agence de
voyage qui est organisée au profit des
jeunes du département en tout cas vous
savez évoqué le logement le travail sont
des problématiques qu'on retrouve dans
l'ensemble de la société ce que les
jeunes qui viennent vous voir vous qui
êtes au contact régulier avec eux sont
inquiets aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est
plus difficile pour eux aujourd'hui
aussi c'est plus difficile oui c'est
plus difficile que ça a été plusieurs
générations avant et voilà on peut même
plus parler de crise parce qu'une crise
c'est censée avoir un début et une fin
et ça fait 40 ans que c'est la crise et
que ça s'aggrave on le voit bien
effectivement il y a une vraie
difficulté
et c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il faut
pas multiplier les nouvelles structure
il faut apprendre à travailler il y a
beaucoup de dispositifs qui existent et
moi ce que je souhaite c'est qu'on
arrive à bien identifier les valeurs
ajoutées de chacun et qu'on aide à
accompagner des jeunes dans un parcours
où la porte d'entrée peut-être un CIO
peut-être le Pôle Emploi peut-être il
vit une information jeunesse et qu'on
puisse bien accompagner les jeunes
jusqu'à réussir leur insertion qui peut
aussi prendre la forme de
l'entrepreneuriat qui peut prendre des
formes très très variées et quelle
échéance vous êtes fixé pour remanier un
petit peu l'information jeunesse le
redéveloppée sur internet sur les
réseaux sociaux revoir un petit peu le
positionnement on sait pas encore fixer
des chances fortes mais voilà on sait
que les deux trois années qui vont venir
vont vraiment être déterminantes donc il
n'y aura pas de révolution dans les
prochains mois en tout cas non ça va se
faire en douceur discuter encore avec
les différents partenaires on discute
avec les différents partenaires qu'on
rencontre voilà moi je suis élu
président depuis un mois donc j'ai pas
encore fait une rencontre tout le monde
rencontrer aussi et ça c'est important
les élus dans les différentes villes où
il y a des points information jeunesse
pour bien expliquer ce qu'est
l'information jeunesse parce que voilà
je crois qu'il y a un service qui est
vraiment irremplaçable notamment autour
de l'initiative des jeunes à monter
leurs projets à monter leur parcours qui
est vraiment une des spécificités de
l'information jeunesse parce que voilà
sur l'aide à l'emploi on n'est pas les
seuls sur le logement n'est pas les
seuls mais sur l'initiative de jeunes
c'est vraiment une de nos valeurs
ajoutées très fortes une dernière
question elle concerne les salariés
parce qu'il y a des salariés dans votre
structure aujourd'hui tout est assuré
sur le paiement de leur salaire sur leur
avenir au sein de l'entreprise
aujourd'hui ils sont payés les missions
sont bien définies donc de ce côté là
encore une fois je remercie le travail
qui a été fait avant la chose sont
saines mais voilà on sait que l'avenir
n'est pas garanti on n'a pas de
d'assurance à de vitaméternam donc il
faudra continuer à être vigilant et
approuvé la valeur ajoutée et l'utilité
de ce service pour continuer
effectivement à assurer le financement
dans les années qui viennent merci
pierre-y d'être venu en plateau et vous
présidente depuis là à rentrer ou les
choses vont mieux mêler encore vous
l'avez dit du travail économie et un
focus à présent sur une activité qui
peut rapporter gros l'exploitation du
safran c'est une des épices les plus
chères au monde 30 000 euros le kilo une
entreprise vient de se lancer dans le
secteur sur Saint-Quentin en Yvelines à
Vic plus précisément Catherine zulator
avec son panier en osier Aurélie Jacques
part à l'accueillette n'ont pas des
champignons c'est de saison mais du
safran une des épices les plus chères au
monde qui se cultivent en pleine terre
là vous avez la première parcelle que
j'ai planté l'année dernière
qui représente à peu près cette année
10000 bulbes donc elle a déjà beaucoup
fleuri là on est en fin de récolte donc
il reste quelques fleurs les fleurs de
crocus sont cueillies le matin car elles
sortent la nuit elles sont ensuite
émondées pour isoler le pistil rouge qui
est la fameuse épice le pissile doit
être immédiatement séché une fois qu'il
aura perdu 80 % de son poids il pourra
être mis en pot sur les parcours bien
c'est parti pour une demi-heure cette
année Aurélie Jacques accueillit 27000
fleurs 15000 bulbes supplémentaires ont
été plantés autant de plantations pour
une production de 300 g seulement de
safran et pour obtenir ces quelques
grammes beaucoup de travail on plante
tout à la main donc on est obligé de
faire une tranchée avec un outil qui
s'appelle une houe et après on plante à
la main à genoux on rebouche on fait les
allées avec une pelle donc déjà c'est
assez physique et après il y a le
désherbage qui se fait aussi à la main
donc moi je ne porte pas de pesticides
et autres le safran intelligent que la
découverte un peu par hasard en 2008 ses
parents agriculteurs décident de prendre
leur retraite se posent la question de
la reprise de l'exploitation céréalière
familiale un voisin vient donner un coup
de main Aurélie imagine de créer
elle-même ses productions et apprend que
le safran pousse en France en 2012 j'ai
fait un stage de chez Véronique lazera
qui a la plus grande safranière de
France et puis je me suis lancé dans
l'aventure j'avais fait un premier test
en plantant mille bulbes et en 2012
l'année dernière j'en ai planté à peu
près 5000 et puis cette année j'en ai
replanté 15000 de plus au total la
journée 25000 cette année la culture du
safran c'est loin loin de l'univers
d'Aurélie la jeune femme travaille dans
la finance pour une société de gestion
d'actifs toute une organisation au
moment de la récolte comme il faut
cueillir les fleurs le matin j'y allais
avant de travailler donc j'y allais avec
une lampe frontale pour cueillir mes
fleurs et puis après j'allais travailler
ma deuxième journée à Paris
cette année Aurélie Jacques a vendu ses
premiers grammes de safran pour l'heure
c'est juste une diversification de
l'exploitation agricole mais à terme
pourquoi pas une vraie petite entreprise
qui pourrait s'annoncer très rentable
car le safran se monnaie 30 000 euros le
kilo il faut entre 150 000 et 200000
fleurs pour en faire un kilo avec un
gramme de safran vous pouvez déjà
parfumer entre 50 et 150 assiettes un
gramme de safran vendu par Aurélie 34
euros en France il n'y a que 157
exploitations de safran pour une
production nationale qui est aussi entre
250 et 300 kg alors que les leaders eux
en Iran produisent entre 160 et 180
tonnes à l'année cela laisse donc
entrevoir de belles perspectives
économiques
nous poursuivons ce journal avec une
rencontre un véritable passionnée dans
un des hangars de l'aérodrome de
Saint-Cyr-l'École Bernard Gauthier qui
ne jure que par l'aéronautique fabrique
lui-même une réplique du chasseur
Mustang cet avion mythique des années à
1940 il devrait même pouvoir le faire
voler et d'ici la fin de l'année si l'on
en croit ce sujet d'Anthony Rey chez de
Patrick Jacques de dixmu
comme tous les jours Bernard Gauthier
part au travail mais son trajet est
plutôt très court car il a élu domicile
juste en face d'un hangar où il
construit la réplique d'un Mustang un
avion de chasse américain des années 40
donc là ça c'est la partie longeron
c'est la partie primordiale de de
l'avion parce que se fixe les trains se
fixe le vérin et puis c'est ce qui fait
la résistance cet ancien salarié d'Air
Inter aéré ses premiers boulons en 1992
avec par moment un arrêt du chantier
seulement pour construire lui-même sa
maison désormais Bernard Gauthier dans
la dernière ligne droite je pense qu'on
fait ça une seule fois dans sa vie on
fait ça une seule fois dans sa vie c'est
c'était un challenge son formation de
mécanicien il est incollable sur la
moindre pièce de son Mustang il a changé
le moteur et à installer un six
cylindres de 350 chevaux pour la
carlingue il a déniché du contreplaqué
et du titane pour de nombreuses rotules
il a d'ailleurs tout fabriqué lui-même à
l'exception de quelques comme le train
d'atterrissage ou encore le système
radio dans le cockpit l'objectif rester
fidèle à son illustre ancêtre j'ai
trouvé des vrais palonniers de Mustang
le manche de Mustang je veux absolument
la conception les banques tout ça
intérieurement tout ça c'est moi qui les
ai fait je ça ressemble à un avion de
guerre je veux pas de GPS je veux pas de
choses comme ça tous les instruments
c'est des vieux instruments qui sont
passés dans des commentaires des
professionnels qui les ont mis en état
ils sont tout neufs mais ce sont des
vieux instruments des manières fruits
des choses comme ça extrêmement d'époque
il est même allé jusqu'à fabriquer des
répliques de mitrailleuses tout cela
pour un investissement total de 40000
euros à 64 ans Bernard Gautier ne compte
plus les heures passées dans ce hangar
son seul but voire voler son bébé et les
le premier décollage est prévu début
2015 mais avis aux intéressés il sera
très compliqué de prendre les commandes
je le dis tout de suite s'il y avait
quelqu'un qui pense qu'un jour s'asseoir
dedans statique nos problèmes le piloter
gros big problème
autre passion qui est le fédère de
nombreuses personnes à travers la France
l'émission question pour un champion il
existe des clubs dans la plupart des
régions des départements notamment dans
les Yvelines Florane parfait sur les
traces de Julien Lepers
top c'est un club qui regroupe 14
personnes il se réunissent tous les
samedis après-midi de 14h à 19h le club
a été fondé en 1999 ses membres ont tous
la même passion c'est le club de
Questions pour un champion de trap à 50
ans en Yvelines comment se nomme le
cardinal qui administre les affaires de
l'église pendant la vacances du
Saint-Gilles
comme dans le jeu ils ont tout pour
s'entraîner des buzzers une console
d'arbitrage et même de vrais champions
Martine et cruciverbiste elle a
participé plusieurs fois à la célébrer
émission je suis comme tout le monde
j'ai des trous il y a des réponses que
je connais et puis
j'ai beau chercher ne remonte pas
forcément à temps parce que question
pour un champion c'est aussi un jeu de
vitesse attrape les adhérents ne sont
plus aussi nombreux qu'avant ils
cherchent à attirer de nouveaux membres
l'engouement pour le jeu touche la
France entière il existe même un réseau
très actif des clubs actuellement à peu
près 180 clubs de question pour un
champion à travers la France et ce sont
tous les clubs qui
fabrique ces questions
où ils auront tous les samedis pas de
compétition sévère ici l'ambiance est
plutôt conviviale
on s'amuse aussi très bien lors de
tournois que nous faisons à travers la
France parce que les clubs organisent
des tournois on se déplace on va en
province ça nous permet de découvrir
souvent certaines régions de nombreux
tournois ont lieu chaque année les
Trappistes ne sont pas en reste même si
aucun n'a réussi à devenir super
champion il y en a des grands champions
les gens qui regardent un tout petit peu
l'émission connaissent tous quand même
ou Karim des gens comme ça bon on n'est
pas à ce niveau là mais
ils sont à table aussi parfois un défi
que Trap est prêt à relever avec
toujours plus d'adhérents à ses côtés
fin du journal demain vendredi vous avez
rendez-vous avec Catherine zulato pour
l'édition du week-end votre soirée sur
tvfils c'est avec Phil écho il sera
notamment question du marché de la mort
et quelques jours de la Toussaint mais
aussi du Salon du Chocolat qui se
déroule actuellement à Paris je vous
retrouve à cette même place dès lundi à
18h en direct